my first role-playing game was Chrono
Trigger I fell in love immediately for a
kid who hadn't yet seen Back to the
Future
squares time-traveling story was a
foreign concept I could battle dinosaurs
repair robots recruit anthropomorphic
frogs I could spend hours with chrono
and Luka prepping for those showdowns
with a parasite Lagos I could finish the
game more than a dozen different ways
all the while mesmerized by the links
between the past present and future
in short Chrono Trigger was a seminal
game for me its ever twisting plot and
colorful characters sparked an intense
love for RPGs specifically those made in
Japan I would later pour hours into
Suikoden - Secret of Mana Super Mario
RPG and most games in the Pokemon series
I love their long-form narratives I
loved grinding for experience
I loved the melodramatic sometimes
surrealistic world building
but as the videogame release schedule
became more crowded and the number of
quality games increased every year I
gradually fell off the JRPG train the
things I loved about the genre in the
first place became the very things that
pushed me away they began to feel too
long
granny began to seem like a waste of
time there's stories felt juvenile and
stacked against the likes of braid
Portal 2 or the Last of Us a magic I
discovered as a kid had all been
evaporated but just weeks ago it all
came rushing back persona 5 is hard to
define so I'll do my best to force it
into a nutshell it's equal parts social
simulator turn-based combat and high
school coming-of-age drama you spend
half of your time in the real world and
half of your time in the meta verse this
alternate reality that serves as the
physical manifestation of human thoughts
and emotions it's kind of like the
matrix and if you played a persona game
before then this is nothing new however
I haven't played a persona game before
this is all new to me I'm not usually
one for anime or high school dramas and
persona games were also notorious for
their length I was content to ignore
them for many of the reasons I ignored
JRPGs for the last 10 years or so yet
for some reason I began persona 5 maybe
it was a jazz infused soundtrack maybe
it was the assertive style it exudes at
every turn regardless it reminded me of
my first time playing chrono trigger all
those years ago after only a few hours I
knew this is a game I can fall into its
world envelops me it's combat entices me
its narrative pulls me in the dichotomy
between its stylized version of Tokyo
and the psychological Metaverse creates
intriguing plot points and nuanced
character studies and it propels both
forward at a confident pace
what's more persona 5 spends much of its
time setting up expectations only to
shatter them down the line it also
suffers most of the JRPG tropes I've
grown tired of over the years it all
begins with the combat as with several
other games in the series persona 5 lets
you negotiate with your enemies during
holdups after you've discerned their
weaknesses and exploited them as well
this not only changes the flow of combat
but it also allows you to absorb the
enemy's power for later use as you
gather more persone
throughout the game negotiations also
ask you to participate intense
conversations with these enemies you
have to read them you have to flirt
insult argue and comfort you tell some
what they want to hear and others what
they don't persona 5 asked you to engage
in verbal jiu-jitsu and it's just as
rewarding as the combat and many other
JRPGs but persona 5 is disruptive on
higher levels - more than anything this
game respects my time it takes more than
100 hours to beat and somehow almost
everyone of them feels integral to the
experience this is largely because of
how persona 5 actually deals with time
many of your missions have deadlines
attached giving you only a couple of
weeks to prepare for your next trek into
the Metaverse where you'll carry out a
psychological heist to give each villain
a real world change of heart
while these time limits could be
damaging in a lesser game persona 5
wields them with expertise gathering
supplies experienced and useful
supporting characters could normally be
a grind towards some arbitrary goal but
there's a certain urgency here that
lends everything more weight with a
looming deadline to consider grinding
becomes a thrill
and that's the thing for sort of five
makes the grind fun it makes it
meaningful when I turn off the game for
the day and I think about my progress I
don't feel like any of my time was
wasted because persona 5 knows time is
important and it's built around that
idea to see this in any game is
impressive but to see in a game this
length is astounding that is each and
every small activity feels important
within the larger game exploring Tokyo's
nightlife improves your social skills
doing laundry cleans valuable equipment
studying increases your knowledge which
aids your relationship with intelligent
characters which grants you new combat
skills and dialogue options and then
there are the relationships themselves
by earning the confidence of your fellow
students and Tokyo citizens you'll build
a ragtag band of thieves and accomplices
gaining notoriety and power in both the
real world and the Metaverse leaving
aside the fantastic dialogue and
heartfelt nature of persona 5 social
aspects it's also just downright fun to
foster these relationships you learn
your allies on personal and functional
levels you gain new skills as you
improve these bonds you form a psychic
army of sorts to take on Tokyo's corrupt
underbelly first one of five social
aspects don't sit apart from its combat
in exploration it's all of a piece what
kind of person do you think I was
there's no way I'd turn out to be some
bad guy in the end right and although
I'm only just beginning to talk about
the characters it's actually here we're
persona 5 is at its most brilliant RPG
characters have this tendency to fall
into categories filling out arc types in
the service of a familiar structure from
game to game
there's the brash rebellious Punk the
antisocial geek the just rule abiding
citizen persona 5 has each of these but
as in the rest of the game it jumps at
the chance to pick these stereotypes
apart just when I thought I knew a
character they revealed something about
their past or their life at home and it
warped my perception in many cases the
game showed how someone might mold their
personality to fit these archetypes
on purpose it's no coincidence that this
unfolds during these characters high
school years it's a time when labels run
rampant amplifying the confusion of
people who don't know who they are or
where they're going the characters and
persona 5 embody this confusion in
spades they're all outsiders they're all
lonely and they deal with it in
different ways through violence
rebellion withdrawal or are
for such a stylistic melodramatic game
persona 5 can be painfully surprisingly
human like its predecessors this is a
game about identity and how its
characters suppress there's only to see
it manifest in the form of powerful
personas in the Metaverse and as they
grow in that psychological world they
grow in the real world too they begin to
express themselves they gain some
semblance of understanding as they
undergo trials and build relationships
I've started several JRPGs in recent
years hoping one of them would pull me
back into the genre I fell in love with
so long ago but the more I tried the
more I felt like giving up it felt like
I was searching for something that
wasn't there yet my favorite games and
movies deconstruct the genres they're
placed in and here is a game that does
just that persona 5 examines the
character archetypes combat systems and
repetitive grinding often attributed to
the JRPG space and flies in the face of
each and every one like its rebellious
subversive characters persona 5 defies
the labels its surface value attracts
[Music]
[Laughter]
there's been a slew of great JRPGs in
the year since I stopped pouring time
into them but like Chrono Trigger all
those years ago persona 5 sparked a
fascination I can't easily ignore it
reminded me why I fell in love with
JRPGs in the first place and I can't
wait to go back and see what I've missed
[Music]
hey everyone thanks so much for watching
the fourth episode of reboot I really
enjoyed talking about persona 5 and Jake
and I really enjoyed doing this show it
helps us a lot when you get your
comments in on youtube and tweet at us
giving us questions comments concerns so
in the meantime when we talk about
persona 5 feedback on next episode get
those comments in and we will also tease
the next episode we'll see you that
[Music]